everybody agrees we need to make even
more than efforts on reconciling working
life and family alive we talked about
equality of opportunities for gays
lesbians bisexuals in Europe oh no hope
on the proposed directive on a better
balance of men and women in executive
boards we presented a compromise
proposal the company Omalu is more
unfortunately I must announce that we
weren't able to find an agreement on
equality between women and men in the
field of decision making it's become
clear that to have lasting progress we
need to implement measures which some of
which are binding and some of which are
voluntary I presented the Commission
strategic engagement on gender equality
for the years 2016 to 2019 this document
reaffirms our priority areas first
increase female labor market
participation and equal economic
independence for men and women second
reducing the gender pay gap cert
promoting equality between men and women
in decision-making force ending
gender-based violence and fifths
promoting gender equality globally as we
all know the economic and social context
in Europe is very fragile even yeah I've
seen some improved growth and
improvement in the unemployment figures
but nevertheless social problems in a
lot of our states are still present and
we got in my proposals that my
commission has emitted reflect the needs
to undertake a certain readjustment of
the semester we have adopted conclusions
on social governance running
rusev Europe so we've made a good start
as nourishment said of the next few
years we really have to work on this to
ensure that this economic growth and
investment can be made in terms of
employment and also the promotion of
existing social security system the
decisions taken today on addressing
long-term unemployment fighting
undeclared work and facilitating demand
and supply on the labour markets are
clearly examples of delivery on the
social economic governance also known as
our European semester